me mandaron un ejercicio que está muy
interesante porque pues no tiene toda la
información completa hay algo que está
fallando ahí o la pregunta está mal
formulada o hay un pedazo de información
que no nos dieron pero pues pensé que
sería buena idea analizar este ejercicio
y tratar de concluir algo a partir de lo
que nos dieron y ver exactamente dónde
falla así es que pues vamos a verlo
entonces nos dan una función
de x que es un polinomio de tercer grado
de hecho es a que es una variable que no
nos dicen cuáles x x al cubo más b otra
variable x cuadrada más c x + b y luego
nos dan unos de los ceros de la función
a qué me refiero con los ceros me
refiero a los puntos donde la gráfica de
la función intersecta al eje de las x
que es de hecho cuando la función toma
el valor de 0 y esos puntos son menos
1,0
y nos dan otro 0 que es 20 obviamente
aquí tienen que tener 0 porque son los
ceros de la función y también nos dan la
ordenada al origen
o
la cual es
como menos
la ordenada al origen es el punto donde
la gráfica de la función intercepta el
eje de las leyes que es simplemente cero
efe de cero y lo que nos preguntan es
cuánto vale a más de más
y esto es igual
cuanto esto es justo lo que nos piden
que encontremos ahora lo primero que uno
puede hacer en este tipo de problemas es
tratar de visualizar estas cosas
entonces vamos a dibujar aquí los ejes
y pues aquí tenemos un polinomio de
tercer grado entonces este polinomio
tiene que tener tres ceros por aquí ya
nos dieron dos de ellos uno de estos
ceros es el menos 10 menos 10 que es
este puntito de aquí el otro 0 es 2 0 1
y aquí está el 20 y nos están dando la
orden nada al origen que es 0 - 2
-1 y -2 entonces lo que nos dice esta
información que nos dieron es que la
gráfica va a pasar por estos tres puntos
ahora como este es un polinomio de
tercer grado tienen que tener tres ceros
el último cero que nos falta podría
estar en cualquier lugar por acá o
incluso por acá o aquí en medio o hasta
podría ser uno de estos 20 repetidos que
tuvieran una multiplicidad de 2 wright
cuando tenemos polinomios los ceros
también pueden ser complejos y entonces
no los veríamos por aquí sin embargo
cuando los ceros son complejos vienen
por pares por parejas con jugadas ok en
los complejos todos los números tienen
su conjugado y los ceros que son
complejos de un polinomio vienen por
parejas de conjugados ahora no me voy a
meter mucho en todo este asunto ahora
aquí lo único que nos falta es un 0
entonces ese 0 no puede ser un complejo
porque si fuera un 0 complejo entonces
su conjugado también sería un 0 y
entonces tendríamos 4
para un polinomio de grado 3 y eso
simplemente no es posible pero no me voy
a meter mucho en este asunto simplemente
sabemos que el otro 0 es real y que
podría ser alguno de estos dos o
cualquier otro número real pero bueno
vamos a ver si podemos encontrar los
valores de cada uno de los coeficientes
de este polinomio para no complicarnos
tanto y hacer las cosas más sencillas
vamos a suponer que el tercer cero de
este polinomio se encuentra por acá que
podría ser cualquiera de estos reales y
entonces la gráfica se va a ver muy
parecido a algo de este estilo
ok en realidad cualquier polinomio de
tercer grado que pase por estos cuatro
puntos son los ceros del polinomio y la
orden nada al origen del polinomio puede
tomar una infinidad de formas que
también podría hacer algo así
sin embargo tampoco me voy a meter con
estos detalles vamos directamente a
tratar de encontrar estos coeficientes a
ver por aquí tenemos que ponerle el
nombre a este otro cero que sabemos que
tiene esta gráfica y pongámosle a esta x
llamémosle r3 y bueno escogí la letra r
porque viene de raíz porque a los
valores en el eje de las x de todos los
ceros se le llama raíz nosotros sabemos
que f de menos uno es igual a cero
entonces el valor de x igual a menos uno
es una raíz
y también sabemos porque aquí tenemos
este cero que f de 2 es igual a 0
entonces el valor de 2 de x igualados
también es una raíz y lo mismo sabemos
por aquí que tenemos otro 0 que es r 3,0
y sabemos que f de r3 es igual a cero
porque así escogimos a este ere 3
entonces x igual a r3 también es una
raíz y cuando tenemos un polinomio de
tercer grado y tenemos sus tres raíces
entonces podemos escribir por aquí x + 1
ahorita va a saber por qué puse más 1 en
lugar de menos 1 por x menos 2
lo mismo esperan un segundo por x menos
r3 ok esto va a ser exactamente igual a
efe de x aunque nos falta un detalle que
es que por aquí tenemos una a entonces
necesitamos poner aquí
porque a la hora de multiplicar x x x
por equis y obtener x al cubo
necesitamos que esté este coeficiente
para que nos quede x al cubo como esta
de aquí y no simplemente x al cubo bien
ahora porque puse x + 1 en lugar de x
menos uno pues porque si tomamos x igual
a menos uno y evaluamos
efe de menos uno aquí lo que nos va a
quedar es a x menos uno más uno y eso es
simplemente cero entonces no nos importa
cuánto valga todo lo demás todo esto es
simplemente cero entonces ya tenemos que
este menos uno es igual a cero lo mismo
pasa con el 2 si ponemos x igualados y
evaluamos
efe de 2 nos queda a por dos más uno por
dos menos dos que es igual a cero
y entonces efe de 2 es igual a 0 como
estábamos buscando y exactamente lo
mismo pasa con r3
pr 3 es bla bla bla bla x r 3 - r 3 que
es simplemente cero ok entonces como
este es un polinomio y las tres raíces
de estos dos polinomios son las mismas y
el coeficiente de x cúbica también es el
mismo entonces estos dos polinomios son
exactamente el mismo ok
este polinomio si es fx como ya habíamos
puesto entonces si encontráramos cuánto
vale r 3 ya tendríamos una muy buena
expresión de cuánto vale cada una de
estas variables en términos de a porque
nada más tendríamos que desarrollar esta
multiplicación y podríamos ver a que
corresponden los coeficientes aunque hay
entonces sería bueno intentarlo por lo
pronto una de las buenas pistas que nos
dieron es la ordenada al origen está
ordenada al origen lo que nos dice es
que f de 0 es igual a menos 2 ok pero
cuánto vale f de 0 si ponemos x igual a
0 efe
pero es igual a 0 0 0 más de aquí y eso
tiene que ser igual a menos 2 así es que
está desde aquí está desde aquí tiene
que ser igual a menos 2 eso es lo que
nos dice esto de la orden nada al origen
entonces pues por lo menos encontramos
uno de estos coeficientes ahora esto
está muy interesante y muy bueno porque
podemos ver cuál es el término
correspondiente a d con esta forma de
escribir al polinomio
a la hora de desarrollar esta
multiplicación lo que hacemos es sumar
todas las combinaciones que podemos
encontrar escogiendo un término de cada
uno de estos tres paréntesis y si en
alguno de estos paréntesis escogemos al
término x entonces pues el término final
que obtengamos de multiplicar los
escogidos en cada uno de los paréntesis
va a pertenecer a alguno de estos
términos entonces si queremos obtener
este término que es el término constante
lo que tenemos que hacer es escoger
estos tres términos que no tienen a
equis y esa es la única forma de obtener
ade ok si no te quedó claro no importa
ponle pausa al vídeo y desarrolla esta
multiplicación de tres binomios y va a
saber que el único término que no tiene
una constante es
no se nos debe de olvidar multiplicar
por la a por uno por menos dos por menos
r3 y el único término constante en este
polinomio que no tiene x es la de ok
entonces te tiene que ser igual a a que
no se nos olvide la nada por uno por
menos dos y por menos r3 aunque ya la
hora de multiplicar estos este menos se
cancela con este menos y nos queda
simplemente 2a por r3 ahora está de
nosotros ya vimos que es igual a menos 2
entonces esto es igual a menos
ahora lo que queremos es encontrar a r3
así es que pues vamos a dividir de los
dos lados entre dos por a y lo que nos
queda es que r 3 es igual a menos 2
entre 2 por ahora o sea menos 1 entre a
ok pues bueno no alcanzamos a resolver
tal cual cuánto vale el r30 pues
encontramos algo que se parece un poco
que es cuánto vale en términos de a que
vale menos 1 / a
entonces vamos a sustituir r3 igual a
menos uno entre a pero otra cosa por
aquí está a está multiplicando a estos
tres paréntesis entonces pues con un
poco de conectividad y aplicando la
propiedad distributiva este polinomio es
igual a x + 1 x x menos dos por a x
menos a r3 ahora este término de aquí
que es a por r 3 pues si sustituimos r3
que es igual a menos uno entre a
entonces ésta se va a cancelar con esta
a y nos va a quedar simplemente menos 1
entonces este polinomio termina siendo x
+ 1 por x menos
a x menos menos 1 pero pues menos menos
un nueva es simplemente más 1 y pues ya
que tenemos esto así vamos a hacer esta
multiplicación para ver cómo nos quedan
los coeficientes porque estos
coeficientes que nos queden tienen que
ser iguales cada uno
correspondientemente
a b c y pues el d ya sabemos que es
menos 2 entonces vamos a multiplicar
primero estos dos paréntesis recuerden
que tenemos que sumar todas las
combinaciones que nos queden debe
multiplicar un elemento de este
paréntesis por otro elemento de este
paréntesis aunque entonces escogemos
esta x por esta x y nos queda x cuadrada
más escogemos este 1 por esta x y nos
queda más x y escogemos esta x y el
menos dos y nos queda menos
2x escogemos el 1 y al menos 2 y nos
queda menos 2 ahora esto de aquí se
puede simplificar porque aquí tenemos x
menos 2x que es simplemente menos x aquí
menos dos más x cuadrado y ahora tenemos
que multiplicar por este otro paréntesis
que lo voy a poner por aquí a x + 1 y
estamos haciendo esta multiplicación a
ver vamos a poner una línea por acá
entonces 1 por este polinomio es
simplemente este polinomio y nos queda x
cuadrada menos x menos 2 y ahora a x x
menos 2 nos queda menos 2
x + a x x menos x nos queda menos
x x al cuadrado y finalmente a x x x
cuadrada nos queda a x al cubo aunque
sumemos estos términos y entonces ya
nada más nos falta hacer esta suma de
polinomios para terminar de multiplicar
estos tres términos entonces nos queda x
al cubo a x al cubo y después menos a x
cuadrado más 1 por x cuadrada y nos
queda más 11 - a menos
por equis cuadrada y sumamos menos 1 por
x más menos 2 y por x así es que pues
vamos a sacar el menos y una vez uno de
aquí más 2
y factor izamos la equis y finalmente el
término constante menos 2 que nosotros
ya sabíamos que tenía que ser menos 2
porque nos dijeron que la ordenada del
origen era igual a menos 2 pero no se
crean que esto de que el término
constante sea igual a menos 2 proviene
únicamente de la información de las
raíces aquí nosotros agregamos la
información de que la ordenada al origen
era igual a menos 2 al encontrar que r3
tenía que ser igual a menos 1 entre a y
sustituirlo por acá para que nos quedara
aquí esté 1 que entonces esté menos 2 lo
encontramos así porque sustituimos r3
igual a menos 1 entre a y sabemos que
erre 3 es igual a menos 1 entre a porque
nos dijeron que este término tiene que
ser igual a menos 2
si es que este es un ejemplo de cómo la
información se conserva y todo se
conecta de formas muy interesantes pero
bueno tenemos que seguir con este
polinomio a ver esto de aquí es de equis
y bueno esto todo este polinomio es tal
cual la solución que estábamos buscando
ok por la forma en la que lo construimos
aquí lo tenemos tenemos los ceros que
nos dieron que son menos 10 y 20 y la
ordenada al origen vale menos 2 caio
entonces este polinomio o de hecho todos
estos polinomios son una solución al
polinomio que ellos nos propusieron ok
porque dije todos estos pues porque aquí
tenemos una arbitraria está a puede
tomar cualquier valor real aunque puede
ser incluso una fracción un número
negativo bueno excepto el 0 porque si a
para igual a 0 éste ya no sería un
polinomio de tercer grado pero fuera de
eso puede ser cualquier número y
entonces pues aquí obviamente
es
este coeficiente de aquí es b porque es
el coeficiente de x al cuadrado y este
coeficiente con tobey al menos de aquí
es igual a c y obviamente este
coeficiente es igual a d
pero eso ya lo sabíamos y entonces pues
la pregunta de cuánto vale a más de más
más de puede tener muchísimas respuestas
y dependen de qué valor le asignemos a a
a ver vamos a ver dos ejemplos para que
veas que hay dos respuestas distintas
ok supongamos que a es igual a no
seríamos uno entonces b tiene que ser
igual a haber es igual a uno menos
o sea que es igual a cero y c es igual a
menos uno más dos por uno o sea menos
tres menos tres
y ahora si ponga lo que ponga como valor
de ha estado siempre va a ser igual a
menos 2 gay con esta hipótesis de que es
igual a 1 tenemos que a más ve más más
de 10 igual a haber uno más 0 -3 haber
uno menos 3 es menos dos más menos 2 es
menos 4 y ahora pues veamos otro ejemplo
que les parece no sé igual a menos 1 les
parece bien bueno a igual a menos 1 ok
eso es lo que estamos suponiendo y
suponiendo esto pues ya tenemos aquí
todo un polinomio que satisface todas
las hipótesis que nos dieron de que los
ceros son menos 10 y 20 y la orden nada
al origen es menos 2 y entonces tenemos
que ver tiene que ser igual
1 - o sea 1 - menos 1 o sea 2 y se tiene
que ser igual a menos uno más dos por
menos uno a ver 2 x menos uno es menos
dos más uno es menos uno y luego tenemos
este menos por aquí entonces tenemos
menos menos uno o sea que tenemos un uno
y finalmente nuestra de que no importa
que apoyamos siempre va a ser igual a
menos 2
así es que pues vamos a hacer las
cuentas de cuánto vale a más de más de
más de y eso vale menos 1 + 2 eso es un
1 más 1 es un 2 menos 2 es igual a 0
aunque entonces esta pregunta con las
hipótesis que nos dieron tiene dos
respuestas distintas y bueno no sabemos
exactamente a cuál de las dos respuestas
quería llegar la persona que
originalmente formuló este problema ni
sabemos qué
pedazo de información es el que falta
aquí pero sólo por curiosidad vamos a
ver qué pasa en este ejemplo vamos a ver
cómo se ve la gráfica si suponemos que a
es igual a 1 entonces nuestra tercera
raíz r 3 se acuerdan de ella es igual a
menos 1 / a&a es igual a 1 la tercera
raíz es menos 1 entre 1 que es
simplemente vamos a ponerlo por aquí r 3
es igual a menos 1
y mira nada más osea si suponemos que a
es igual a 1 entonces nuestra tercera
raíz es igual a menos 1 aunque ya
tenemos por ahí qué
es igual a 1 r 3 es igual a menos 1 así
es que esta tercera raíz este puntito
amarillo tiene que estar aquí justo
donde estaba la primera raíz que nos
dieron aquí entonces este 0 es un cero
de multiplicidad dos o igual esta raíz
es una raíz de multiplicidad dos se está
repitiendo así es que la raíz no tiene
que estar en ningún otro lado y pues si
te da mucha curiosidad ver cómo se vería
la gráfica en ese caso pues vamos a usar
nuestra calculadora texas para calcular
la gráfica
y entonces tenemos aquí nuestra
calculadora texas y tenemos de 1 igual a
haber aquí está la variable x al cubo
más bueno no tenemos término x cuadrada
entonces le ponemos un cero y nos queda
menos 3x y finalmente menos 2 aunque ya
es nuestra primera función que queremos
graficar porque no graphic hemos de una
vez el segundo ejemplo aunque entonces
vamos a poner una 2 igual tenemos que es
igual a menos 1 entonces ponemos menos x
al cubo b es igual a 2 entonces queda
más 2 por x al cuadrado más
1 que es la ce por x
y lo tenemos y finalmente -2 y le
ponemos graficar y ahí está nuestra
gráfica
pues si se fijan en nuestra primera
función allí salió que tenemos una raíz
doble y ahí está la otra gráfica y
podemos ver que hay las dos gráficas
tienen un cero de menos 10 las dos se
intersectan en la ordenada al origen
menos 2 pero la segunda gráfica tiene a
este otro 0 por ahí las dos tienen un 0
en 20 mientras que la primera gráfica
cuando pusimos a igual a 1 tiene un
doble cero aquí justo en menos 10 bueno
me pareció que era un ejercicio muy
interesante o sea porque tuvimos que
hacer un bonche de cosas que uno
usualmente no hace y pues me gustaría
dejar claro que por cada valor de a
tenemos una solución distinta a este
polinomio y en general vamos a tener
muchas soluciones a estas sumas de
coeficientes